tu veux faire un tube plus que ma mère
ouais alors mais se réchauffer on voit
que tu pues de la tomate en perdent
[Musique]
europe a fait la faute ça va être une
solution
ça va être bon geremi ceux qui se font
du bien tu as quatre enfants trois
quatre enfants et doux avec can't beat
les appels et kenneth promène sur la
plage les abf et regarde un oiseau mort
et qu'elle y est ré où ça les cherry
dans un instant on va jouer sur leur
embargo pages web
[Applaudissements]
mais seule la balance comporte
[Rires]
c'est un mec qui a gagné 400 millions
d'euros au loto et des balles à paris
oui bonjour monsieur je vous appelle
pour la chicha oui elle est vendue non
non non elle est à combien vérifie tipis
des cucquois tu passes une annonce ne
connaît pas le prix bon bah c'est quoi
votre prix monsieur celui d'annick et
mais j'ai pas lalonde était plus du cul
ou quoi je n'ai pas l'annoncent c'est
sarah et rentrer dans l'appartement une
blague crime
oui elle rentre dans la bataille en live
sur le plateau qui se dessine maintenant
regarde le picasso y voit une tache sur
le picasso et se rapprochent picasso et
raya marquer ça elle comprend pas on
regarde le renoir en face à une tâche
renoir est rayé ya marqué saravah dans
le bureau et regarde le van gogh vincent
mallet ya marqué sahara fait david david
question avec les tableaux fais ta
gueule j'ai un contrôle fiscal
j'ai tout mis attendais tu feras tu
public et ma mère ouais alors
chanter on va faire un petit plus de la
tomate en perdre c'est toi qui lui font
c'est moi ouais les deux mois si je peux
lui faire moi elle va me défoncer mais
ça peut être drôle si tu préfères la
défense et ça va ma petite poulette du
pdq toi tu peux plus du cul esther tue
plus du tu t'es plus que toi même tu pue
du cul hester
[Applaudissements]
pas une petite encore avant qu'on fasse
le pacte est malade 1 à l'origine est
mal alors les évêques qui ça ils
s'angoissent il appelle les toubibs y
trouveriez normal à l'hosto effet une
batterie d'examens et trouve rien puis
la santé décline de jour en jour il ya
un évêque fait les mecs personne connaît
un médecin un peu parallèle un rebouteux
je sais pas il y en ai vécu six mois je
connais un type qui est bien il ya du
prompteur et les ventes alice tout ça il
a des résultats ils font venir le mec et
le sculpte le pape pendant deux heures
il est jeune solution il faudrait qu'ils
baisent regardons les sélects quoi mais
ça va pas c'est pas beau et frais qui se
vident les couilles papale saluer
remettra les méridiens s'ouvrira les
chaque race alors l'énergie reviendrai
mais bon on peut pas laisser crever
d'accord on le fait mais le chef des
évêques fait à trois conditions la [ __ ]
faut qu'elle soit aveugle faut qu'elle
soit muette et surtout qu'elle était
très gros nichons
il ya un évêque c'est pourquoi des très
gros nichons l'autre et parce qu'il
adore ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]